hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american australian science
fiction thriller film called 222.
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie starts as a man walks through
the grand central station new york with
a gun in his hand
people around him notice the gun and
start running away he walks to another
man who seems to be protecting a girl
both the men point guns at each other
when the security stops them
the camera pans to a clock which shows
that the time is exactly 2 22.
then we can hear gunshots turns out it
was just a dream
a man named dylan wakes up from his
dream and progresses with his routine
listening to the news the news talks
about a star called hamlin that died out
30 years ago
but its light is reaching the earth 30
years later and that this supernova will
have effects on the earth and its
inhabitants
dylan is then shown on his way to work
riding a bike and heading to the grand
central station to take
the train he works as an air traffic
controller with serious talent and
visualizing patterns
after work he goes to a club drinking
with his co-workers
and receives a ticket to an aerial
ballet as a gift for his upcoming
birthday
the following day at work he starts to
see constellation patterns in front of
him
he starts to hallucinate about his
recurring dream and cannot communicate
with airplanes
he looks at the clock to see it is
exactly 2 22.
looking closely he realizes that the
clock has stopped
dylan comes back to his senses only when
his colleagues call him
dylan notices that the planes are about
to crash into each other due to his paws
he quickly reports to the pilots and
saves them from crashing by an inch
the passengers inside the planes are
relieved dylan notices that the clock
has started working again
due to this incident he is suspended for
four weeks
the day after he was suspended he
attends the aerial ballet
where he sees a woman named sarah and is
stunned by her beauty
after the ballet is over everyone is at
the after party
dylan approaches sarah and introduces
himself
they go to a restaurant and start
talking dylan tells sarah that his
father was a pilot and that he also
trained to be a pilot but could never
become one
as he was afraid of flying sarah tells
him that she works at the howard pace
art gallery
he also tells her about being suspended
from work and he finds out that sarah
was on the plane that almost collided
with the other aircraft at 2 22pm
dylan felt apologetic about the incident
but sarah was instead thankful towards
dylan for saving her life
as they depart they admit to each other
that for a first date
they felt a deep connection and it felt
like they had known each other forever
the following day while on the way to
the grand central dylan notices the same
happenings as the day before
siren a woman laugh construction sounds
a man saying may i help you and glass
breaking as he arrives at the grand
central station
at 2 21 pm he sees a businessman reading
his newspaper
a couple hugging each other a line of
preschoolers where the last child in
line dropped something
and a pregnant woman under the clock at
exactly 2 22 p.m
the window of the station chatters he
then goes to meet sarah and asks her out
to an early dinner
he goes to central park with her for ice
cream sarah reveals that she had stopped
dancing because of an injury
dylan feels bad so to cheer her up he
plays a song and starts dancing in front
of her
she joins him in the two happily dance
together in the middle of a busy park
in the end they kiss they go to dylan's
apartment and make love
the next morning they lie on the bed and
cuddle dylan asks sarah where she got
her necklace from
to which sarah replies that it was from
her ex-boyfriend jonas
who happens to be the main artist of the
gallery at which she works
dylan asks when is sarah's birthday and
they find out that both of them were
born on the same day
april 18th 1986 and they are both
turning 30 within a week's time
dylan suddenly hears a car crash on the
road below his apartment at exactly 9
15 a.m and he tells sarah that it is the
third day in a row that the same
incident had happened
dylan then takes a cab going to grand
central
as the driver takes the shorter route
dylan tells him to stop the cab and
notices again the same pattern of siren
a woman laugh construction sounds and a
man saying may i help you
dylan then shouts for the cab to stop
and this infuriates the cab driver
who turns around to tell dylan off for
shouting at him
just then another car hits them both
causing the breaking of the cab's glass
windows
even though dylan is injured he goes to
the grand central station and sees the
exact same pattern of events
a businessman stands with a newspaper an
older couple hugs
a group of kids walks in a line when the
last kid drops something
and lastly a pregnant woman stands under
the clock
he tells sarah these repeating patterns
but with different people carrying out
the same actions
sarah does not believe dylan but helps
to clean his wounds from the car
accident
dylan goes home and starts writing all
the events of his day
starting from 9 10 a.m first he writes
about the drop of water
then a bug dying and a plane flying
overhead
the following day dylan goes to the top
of his apartment building to see if the
pattern repeats itself
he waits for the drop of water like
yesterday but the sky is clear
however exactly at 9 10 again a drop
falls onto his notebook
surprised he closes the notebook and
when he opens it there is a squash bug
on the page
then an airplane flies over him the
pattern has repeated itself
dylan almost cannot believe it dylan
goes to the gallery looking for sarah
and realizes that the gallery was having
an exhibition with jonas art piece as
the main exhibition
jonas is sarah's ex-boyfriend he has
created a light hologram exhibition
about the grand central station
and dylan sees that it is exactly like
the events that he has experienced in
the past few days
a businessman reading his newspaper a
couple embracing each other
a line of preschoolers and a pregnant
woman under the clocks
dylan assumes that jonas is stalking him
as only dylan knows about these events
he attacks jonas resulting in a brawl he
questions jonas on whether he was
stalking him
in the audience is the owner of the
kiefer gallery he applaud saying it was
a great idea to enact the murder at the
grand central station that happened 30
years ago
sarah apologizes to jonas about dylan's
attack and puts her relationship with
dylan on hold
later that day dylan texts sarah to beg
for her forgiveness
in the meantime he finds a stack of
envelopes hidden in his home
he finds out a man named jake redmond
had written these letters to a woman
named evelyn
upon investigation dylan finds out that
jake redmond lived in his apartment 30
years ago
back in 1987. he also finds an article
online and finds out about the murder
that happened thirty years ago in grand
central
jake redmond was the murderer he killed
his lover evelyn and a police officer in
the middle of the grand central
evelyn was even pregnant at that time
the murder occurred exactly at 2
22. jay killed evelyn out of jealousy
because evelyn was in love with the
police officer
noah marx whom jake killed that day too
he also finds that jake evelyn him and
sarah share the same birthday
in fact he and sarah were born on the
day jake and evelyn died
dylan connects the dots and figures out
that he and sarah are
jake and evelyn in another life then he
finds evelyn's address in the letters
and visits her home
dylan meets evelyn's sister who tells
him that evelyn loved jake a lot
so she thinks the theory that jake
killed evelyn because she loves someone
else is false
she also informs him that noah the
police officer was in love with evelyn
too
when dylan gets back home he links the
constellation that is taking place
after 30 years in their situation he
sees that the three stars involved in
the constellation are actually jake
evelyn and noah currently is dylan sarah
and jonas
since the constellation has returned
their fate has returned to
he texts sarah about what he has been
seeing and asks her to meet him
sarah is in the gallery looking at
jonas's holograms
she tells jonas about dylan's findings
but jonas dismisses it as dylan's
delusions
later that day dylan is in his apartment
when sarah visits him
she sees him distressed and tries to
console him dylan tells her that since
the following day is their birthday
there is a chance he can kill her like
jake killed evelyn
so he tells her to go away and never
meet him again for their own good
after sarah leaves dylan loses control
and starts breaking things around his
apartment
he then goes to the terrace with the
intention of jumping off the building
but he changes his mind sarah on the
other hand
goes to jonas's office and tells him
everything that happened
jonas offers to take her on vacation to
get her mind off dylan
the following morning dylan realizes
that the water drop
the bug the plane and everything that
happens in the pattern
happened to jake the day he died the
pattern has been trying to inform dylan
that sarah is in danger
after figuring this out dylan runs to
save her he calls her several times on
the way but she doesn't pick up
so he goes to jonas's office there he is
shocked to see
a wall filled with sarah's pictures and
several holograms of her
he realizes that jonas is obsessed with
sarah he also finds an empty case of a
gun
and is now sure that sarah is in danger
he rushes to the station to find her
jonas and sarah are in the grand central
station buying the tickets for their
journey
jonas tells sarah to wait for him under
the clock history is repeating itself
jonas returns to her with the tickets he
too realizes that they are living their
past
sarah tells him that she cannot go with
him because she is in love with dylan
agitated he asks sarah to tell him that
she loves him but sarah refuses just as
dylan arrives at the station
jonas thinking that sarah called him
there gets enraged and makes his way
towards dylan with a gun
sarah begins to see the same characters
that dylan had described
the businessman the couple who hugs the
children and so on
she comes to realize that everything
that dylan said was true
but that also means the pregnant woman
under the clock is sarah herself
jonas first points his gun towards dylan
and then he points to sarah
saying that if he couldn't have her
neither could dylan dylan shield sarah
just in time
but he gets shot at 2 21 pm the events
from 30 years ago plays out
and at exactly 2 22 p.m jonas gets shot
by the police who have followed dylan
there
dylan falls in sarah's arms and
momentarily closes his eyes
he has visions of jake and evelyn being
affectionate
luckily he does not die sarah then looks
at the clock
it is 2 23 p.m they managed to survive
and fate has changed
we finally get to know that in the past
life too the police officer noah was the
one who killed evelyn and jake but the
police had turned the story around to
save their reputation
the dying star hamlin mentioned at the
start of the movie finally disappears
but a new star is immediately reborn
in the ending scene it is shown that
dylan and sarah are living happily
with dylan having finally overcome his
fear of flying and is now a pilot
and sarah smiling affectionately at
their baby in the cradle
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching